bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados
desde que el director ejecutivo de
facebook mark zuckerberg que anunció el
cambio de nombre de su empresa a meta y
que es un nuevo proyecto en el futuro
cercano se centraría en el metaverso la
palabra está en boca de todos pero lejos
de ser un concepto nuevo la idea de
metaverso ya existía hace varios años de
hecho la acuñó el escritor nil
stephenson en 1992 en su libro de
ciencia ficción snow catch pero que es
el metaverso shaker break lo presenta
como el sucesor de la internet móvil y
como la nueva frontera para conectar a
las personas lo podríamos definir como
el futuro de la realidad virtual un
espacio al que podrán acceder millones
de usuarios para reunirse de trabajar e
ir de compras o incluso presenciar
conciertos
facebook por ejemplo lanzó horizon work
roms espacios virtuales para realizar
reuniones laborales en una sala de
encuentros virtual
pero también estaría la posibilidad de
reunirse con familiares que viven en
distintas partes del mundo o bien hacer
ejercicio de forma remota acceder a
clases virtuales o crear nuevos empleos
con la ayuda de gafas de realidad
virtual entraríamos con lo que se llama
un avatar es decir un personaje que nos
representaría en ese universo con ello
se espera también un boom económico con
un sinfín de productos virtuales que
estarán a la venta y es que hasta la
moda ya incursiona en el terreno marcas
como nike o vans ya han anunciado que
fabricar zapatillas netamente virtuales
y h&m anunció una colección para vestir
nuestros futuros avatares en otras
palabras es un mundo abierto de
posibilidades para creadores y
empresarios la potencialidad que tiene
de acercar el mundo de ponernos o darnos
acceso a lugares donde no tendríamos
acceso de otra manera a formación a
educación la posibilidad de trabajar y
aunque ya existen experiencias de
realidad virtual como fernando o
minecraft
verso no es un juego sería más bien una
realidad extendida a nuestras vidas las
herramientas que trae el metaverso
desarrollado o puesto que podríamos
llamar ya la siguiente generación de
estas tecnologías es la posibilidad de
actuar en el mundo en un mundo digital
como si estuviéramos en el mundo real y
tener impacto sobre ese mundo real el
metaverso aún no existe a gran escala y
muchas compañías están apostando a crear
metaversos como los operadores de
telefonía vodafone de españa' o sk
telecom de corea del sur y todavía no se
sabe si cada uno de estos metaversos
estarían conectados unos con otros es
decir si se podrá viajar de una
experiencia a otra además para que todo
esto sea posible no basta con la
tecnología actual y sería necesario
crear una red 5g muy potente para
soportar los metaversos y que ejércitos
de desarrolladores de programas en los
próximos años creen estos espacios
virtuales aunque facebook busca ser el
pionero su líder genera un sinfín de
interrogantes si uno mira las patentes
que han salido en los últimos meses
asociado por ejemplo este tema de
metaversos desde el lado de facebook o
de meta en ningún lado se está hablando
de privacidad sí pero si se está
hablando de poder tomar más información
del usuario a facebook precisamente no
se le conoce por su transparencia en la
utilización de datos de sus usuarios y
viene de protagonizar varios escándalos
como los revelados por la ex empleada de
esa compañía francés haugen quien filtró
archivos internos que evidencian que la
compañía antepuso sus intereses
financieros a la regulación de
contenidos engañosos o a la afectación
psicológica en los adolescentes es
ilógico pensar que esta compañía que ha
tenido todos estos problemas asociados a
la seguridad y privacidad de sus
usuarios y al manejo de la información
sea aquella que hoy está abanderando el
tema del pitazo y la competencia será
feroz bloomberg intelligence se estima
que para 2024 la industria del metal eso
generará 800 mil
de dólares y market research future
considera que para 2030 este mercado
crecerá anualmente un
41,7 por ciento y en medio de la
competencia por el dominio del metaverso
tanto posibles usuarios como expertos se
preguntan quién lo regulará el problema
con las nuevas tecnologías es que las
regulaciones suelen llegar después y se
teme a que quienes controlen este nuevo
universo sean las empresas que lo creen
anteponiendo sus propios intereses y
dejando por fuera del radar aspectos
como la propagación de la desinformación
la expansión de los discursos de odio la
prevención para la usurpación de
identidades o la manipulación de datos
personales los mayores retos que veremos
están asociados a privacidad
definitivamente a manejo de datos a
crear para tener en cuenta a todos los
demás es decir el tema de que seamos y
creemos herramientas y plataformas que
son realmente incluyentes también
quedará por ver si el metaverso logrará
conectarnos tal y como lo propone en
facebook o si por el contrario nos
dejará aún más divididos y alejados de
la realidad si les sirvió el vídeo para
entender el metaverso y sus desafíos los
esperamos en otro nuevo episodio de en 5
minutos aquí en france 24
[Música]